danke danke ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß
ich stehe meine lieben freunde das
könnte daran nehmen dass ich stehe
mir geht's auf jeden fall schon deutlich
besser als die letzten tage von daher
habe ich mich von meinem stuhl enthobene
und bin da gibt es das wort enthoben
keine ahnung mit solchen wörtern unter
anderem setzen wir uns allerdings in der
heutigen episode e mail fällt auch
auseinander denn wir haben wieder einige
rechtschreibfehler am start starten
jedoch nicht direkt mit dem
rechtschreibfehler sondern mit diesen
bfl und zwar verkauft jemand an seinem
golf 4 für 1000 franken aus mehrstetten
kommt er und der grund warum er den
verkauft ist verkaufe golf 4 wegen habe
ich ein flugzeug
[Musik]
ich bin echt gut da kam fast mittagessen
hoch dass der nächste iwf hält und zwar
verkauft dort jemand tragischerweise
leider seinen hund schreibt allerdings
in den titel der ebay anzeige kurzhaar
qi wow wow ja ich würde nämlich wollten
langhaar collie krieg holen sprachen
lernen dadurch dass jetzt der nächste
fehler und man sieht glaube ich dass das
eine friteuse ist in den titel steht
allerdings zu früh töte mitgas punkt
gastronomin gas früh töte ja ich glaube
da kannst du früchte drin fried sieht
die sache allerdings geht weiter mit dem
nächsten ebay kleinanzeigen feld und
zwar hat der interessent eine komische
frage es war fragt der hallo ich hätte
eine frage bezug auf die anzahl der
hände die der wagen bereits hat halo
dominik das auto hat keine hände oder
was meinst du und dann schreibt er eine
stunde später eine neue nachricht und da
hat einfach dem autohändler gemalt ich
hab den ball zwei hände dran gemacht
passt das ja also jetzt würde ich es
nehmen weil ein auto ohne hände kommt
bin ich in der garage
der nächste eckball verpasste der tv
show die vor einigen tagen im fernsehen
lief habt ihr das gesehen dieses pocher
gegen wendler er das war echt schlag den
raab das ist auf jeden fall der ebay
fail und zwar verkauft dort jemand ein
regal also ein egal regal quasi in der
beschreibung steht verkaufe ein ikea
regal dass er egal ist jünger als laura
und kann gerne für zehn euro gekauft
werden bilder auf anfrage ich find's
lustig wenn er geschrieben hätte bilder
und das hier ist der nächste ebay fail
und zwar ist ein druckluft gerät was man
auch der betriebsanleitung oben
entnehmen kann
er schreibt allerdings den titel das ist
eine frühe ding 35 euro und wer will
einfach fragen ich weiß nicht wie dieses
ding heißt ja du hast es doch gekauft
und zudem steht in der betriebsanleitung
also herr
ich kann kein englisch das hier ist der
nächste ebay verkauft dort jemand window
colour bilde ich weiß allerdings nicht
ob das wirklich eine person verkauft die
auch window colour bilder malt weil so
wie er window colour bilder schreibt
liegt das auf jeden fall nahe am
nächstenliebe fällen geht es um ein
iphone 10s und der verkäufer fragt den
potenziellen käufer ist ihnen der preis
zu hoch
märz nicht hey sie schreiben mich an ich
antworte human wie ein normaler mensch
und sie fangen grundlos an mich zu
beleidigen dürfte ich fragen wo ihr
problem liegt ich habe eine 5
geschrieben in physik 2
also dann ist das voll verstehen machen
wir nun allerdings direkt wieder weiter
mit einer komischen ebay konversation
und zwar schreibt dort ein interessent
mein interesse war sehr groß und ich war
bereit mehr zu zahlen aber jetzt gucke
ich mich anderweitig um
guten tag machen sie das lag mir die
tischbeine du laxen nacken
ja
die nicht den lasten der verkauft jemand
eine bassbox mit endstufe von sony und
die unterhaltung lief schon ein bisschen
voller schreibt der potentielle käufer
nun okay der verkäufer antwortete
daraufhin mittwoch geht doch nicht
freitag geht und der interessent er
wieder daraufhin ok alles k
8 erste meint alex alexa dann darf sich
der meister vielleicht den verkäufer
dass der so heißt aber der mann ist
wirklich alles klar
und daher empfehle ich dir kommen wir
nun allerdings noch mal zu so einem
enorm kranken deutschen rechtschreibung
fehler und zwar schreibt er eine person
guten tag der audi wurde soeben verkauft
und die andere person antwortet ja
also ich mir nun wieder zu einem
chronischen verlauf und zwar schreibt er
eine person hallo ich heiße der name ist
natürlich zensiert würden sie die ps3
auch für 25 euro abgeben will noch
schüler und bin selber gerade klar kein
grund so zu schreien alles in
großbuchstaben und jetzt antwortete
interessent wieder weil ich alles groß
geschrieben habe ich habe die groß
stellt taste an gemacht weil ich dann
keine großteil rechtschreibfehler mache
ja dinger der typ ist schülern und der
ist schlau wie sonst was am nächsten
die bfl haben wir ein richtiges
verhandlungslinie am start und zwar
schreibt der interessent zum beispiel
wie viel euro daraufhin der verkäufer
1200 letzte preis
sorry zu teuer tschüss 200
wie viel denn maximal 400 alles klar der
2 hier sucht ein ruhiges paar eine
zentrale zwei zimmer wohnung und eine
person schreibt ihnen einfach
frauentausch dann schreibt allerdings
noch eine nachricht und zwar spaß war
nicht mehr lustig sorry allesklar de
hast ja jetzt selbst verstanden von
daher geht es weiter mit dem nächsten
fehler dieser hier tauscht die rhi um
gegen iphone 11 je nach zustand des
iphones ist noch eine zu zu tun
das hier ist der nächste ebay fell und
zwar ist das eine perücke die verkauft
wird vor allem mit zum richtigen
bescheuerten im modder daneben mit zu
herzen den augen allerdings beschreibt
er dieses produkt hat in seinem titel
als prekär
ich habe es echt war
wir klatschen rufen lasst ihr eigentlich
das ist so oder so dass jetzt der
nächste ebay fällen und zwar verkauft
hat jemand eine casio uhr und ein
potenzieller käufer fragt hallo tauschen
sie die uhr auch gegen eine andere uhr
auf meinem profil finden sie einige
uhren liebe grüße hey nein danke will
noch verkaufen was spricht gegen einen
tausch dass ich geld will und keinen
anderen gegenstand will beziehungsweise
braucht geld bekommt man ja durch den
arbeitsplatz und man kann immer eine
neue uhr gebrauchen also warum tauschen
sie nicht weil ich nicht will was ist
der grund dafür dass sie nicht wollen
das ist der grund die pappnase ich will
einfach nicht ja warum tauscht denn
nicht mein gott jeder braune und geld
hast du noch genug am arbeitsplatz und
beim nächsten event fällen haben wir
wieder einen komischen interessenten und
zwar fragt der halo ist es noch
verfügbar
halo ist es noch verfügbar halo ist es
noch verfügbar haben sie einen schlag an
[Musik]
inzwischen sich so einen reizhusten
immer wenn ich
was hässlich es doch
ich habe euch lieb mädels das hier ist
die überschrift vom nächsten ebay
angebot und zwar seht ihr schon mercedes
abzugeben und da denkt man sich jetzt
vielleicht haye der hat mercedes ihnen
die falsch geschrieben blabla irgendwie
mit max jedes oder irgendwie so war der
meint wirklich ein mac mercedes in der
ersetzt selbst gebaut hat aus macdonald
ja gut da
ich würde dir 17 millionen euro dafür
geben und hier verkauft die man 175
quadratmeter wohnfläche komplett neu
renoviert inklusive heizung für einen
verhandelbaren preis von 219.000 euro
990 und er schreibt da noch drunter
normalpreis 300.000 euro habe zehn euro
reduziert damit wir beim
vertragsabschluss kebab essen gehen
können
der mann
man denkt outside of the board bei
diesem liebefeld frage ich mich
überhaupt was das gerade für eine
situation beziehungsweise konversation
uns vorschreibt eine person vielleicht
können sie sie in der nähe des
überdachten aquariums fangen ich kannst
du dir nach hause kommen weil ich ein
auto sein werde
die andere person antwortete daraufhin
ganz klar bitte was und fragt was los
ist und daraufhin antwortet die andere
werte und wieder ist es besser fische zu
fangen wenn das licht aus ist das anders
hier verkauft jemand autos ticker nach
wunsch und ein interessent schreibt ihm
hallo würde gerne ein 80 cm langes zwei
zentimeter hohes als sticker haben motiv
ein golf 2 cl als bild und darunter die
schriften bei redcoon ingolf
entwicklungen golf haben sie eine
vorlage
nein leider nicht haben sie einen
entwurf wie sich das ganze vorstellen
und schickt das hier
ich
bildschirme ja gar nicht wissen wir auch
dass leute im video geklatscht haben wir
nun allerdings auch schon zu den letzten
beiden ebay fällt allerdings sind sie
zwei wieder als rhein verpackt und der
erste lautet rose sind rot bei metall
hat man die wahl deshalb gönne ich mir
briefkasten mit zeitungs rolle edelstahl
ja und der nächste fall ist rose sind
roten nadine marx erdberg asse und
leberwurst und vergnügt sich gerne im
bett mit matratzen und lattenroste
ja
haben wir den tiefpunkt wieder erreicht
und an der stelle meine lieben freunde
wie ich das heute ich mich jetzt auch
beenden wenn euch die heutige wieso die
ebay fans mit luca gefallen hat dann
zeigt mir gern mit einer bewertung unter
dem video schaffen wir 50.000 like für
krank hohe zahl wird mich auf jeden fall
freuen weil es noch kein abonnent zeit
von meinem kanal abonniert den gern
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
ja
mehr gründe kann ich euch dafür nicht
nennen weil es ist halt eigentlich eine
einschränkung der lebensqualität wenn
man sich meine videos jeden tag zu
gemüte führt
[Musik]